even though fruit and other carbohydrate
foods are perfectly fine for health for
some folks I find that there's a mood
boosting effect to having specifically
some plant protein early in the day and
early in the meal let's say my breakfast
started off with some grilled tempeh
some tofu and then follow that with some
green vegetables or some oatmeal I find
that I personally feel more balanced
than if I didn't have that plant protein
the opposite example is in France where
people start every day with just a
pastry or something like that and a
really dysfunctional way of doing it is
to do it with sausage or bacon where
it's protein but it's a big mixture of
protein and animal fat and cholesterol
and glop that does more harm than good
but with plant protein starting off
earlier in the meal and earlier in the
day I find that my energy is better for
the rest of the day